[Music]
the tour of the weekly wash you might
not know it but in each load you close
release hundreds of thousands of tiny
fabric fibers many of which contain
plastic from the dirty washing water
they soon get into the environment
poisoning our waterways and the food
chain substantial numbers of
commercially important fish and
shellfish are now contaminated with
small pieces of plastic including fibers
and I see because those fibers won't
degrade unless we start to take action
to reduce those imports we are only
going to see more and more in the marine
life so these bigger bits of plastic
that have washed up on this Beach are
clearly easy to spot but what's worrying
about microfibers is you can't really
see them and so they're easier for
animals to ingest so we're going to take
this sample back to the lab to get a
closer look at it under the microscope
the problem is clear these samples
contain suspected micro fibers and will
be sent off for further analysis and
here more evidence this time in both a
sea bird and a fish's stomach figure
theme by Sky News show that around a
hundred and ninety thousand tons of
plastic from our clothes make their way
into our oceans every year that's the
equivalent of one thousand three hundred
and fifty-seven blue whales and
significantly more than the 35,000 tons
of plastic that comes from cosmetics but
this clothes recycling factory Sophie
Mather who's worked in the industry for
decades tells me why she's taking action
she's carrying out research to introduce
new technology which would change how
textiles are actually produced the
fashion industry really needs to a lot
more about this I mean we're seeing
these sorts of fabrics here the fleece
fabrics we know are really bad culprits
all of the fabrics really have an issue
with fibers coming out but it's these
ones here that lose a lot every time
you're washing them and we need to
understand more about it so we contacted
ten of Britain's top retailers even
though all of them were aware of the
micro fibers issue only one company H&M
was actually doing anything about it
research suggests its older fabrics that
the most microfibers but without changes
and support from retailers experts
warned that the problem will only get
worse
Rebecca Williams Sky News Plymouth